homicide rates in U.S cities all blew up
somewhere around the mid 20th century
Baltimore's homicides went up by 346
percent from 1950 to 1991.
346 percent Chicago's homicide rate went
up by 322 percent Detroit went up by
1400 New York City's by 692 percent New
Orleans by 504 percent San Francisco by
128 and so on okay we could go on and on
in all these cases Helton notes homicide
rates were higher in 1991 than they were
in the early 1900s before the invention
of antibiotics and and modern surgical
techniques what these figures
demonstrates is that
the violence we accept as normal is in
fact a choice it is normal now it
doesn't need to be
it's not inevitable it's not just like
how cities always are